hey guys it's justine and today we're
going to be unboxing and checking out
the brand new macbook air that apple
just released and i always get so
excited to open stuff up with a knife
but apple
makes it way too easy and we don't need
a knife
ah look at
you look at you
this is such a great color
oh they call it gold but in my eyes
this pink
oh that smells good take a smell of that
guys
you know you're smelling your screens
right now don't even try to act like
you're not
so it has a 13.3 inch retina led display
1.1 gigahertz quad-core intel core i5
512 gig solid-state drive with eight
gigs of ram it's got the new backlit
magic keyboard it also has touch id and
it weighs 2.8 pounds this really is a
very powerful tiny little machine and
you can really do anything you need on
this thing i was editing videos on the
previous version and now that this one
has 80 faster graphics that'll
definitely help out in the video
production department as well as editing
photos and of course playing games and
watching youtube videos let's be real i
have spilled all of my i've spilled my
drink my foot's wet oh
god justine my foot is soaking wet with
yerba mate right now
there's still a little bit left i'm
gonna go get another sock and another
drink and maybe i'll get a towel to
clean this up
[Music]
i'm back
so let's just look at this beautiful
gold color it's so light that is the
appeal of the macbook air is how light
it is this really is a perfect little
tiny computer so that's turning on let's
see what else is inside of the box or a
usbc charging cable the gold stickers
i really use english is the main
language press the return key
all right
and last but not least is our little
usb charging brick this is a really
great charging brick i actually use this
contains a built-in screen reader called
voiceover for if you know how to use
voiceover press command
and we are all set up there is nothing
better than a nice
fresh smelling mac like this is
everything is so clean and new the arrow
keys are also new so this is to mimic
the 16 inch macbook pro keyboard you can
tell that they're way more separated so
if you're not looking at your keyboard
you can tell
which keys are which and that's in
comparison to this one which is the old
keyboard so there really is a huge
difference this is the new scissor
mechanic keyboard there is a lot more
give when you press the keys down so i
just realized my microphone wasn't on
it's like i've never made a youtube
video before so one of the things that's
really great is apple does have
education discounts so if you are in
school you can get this macbook starting
at 8.99 for all of us that aren't
students it starts at 9.99 it comes in
three different colors we've got a space
gray we've got the gold and the silver
there's also two different options
depending upon which storage size so
there's the 256 that starts at 8.99 and
if you want to up the storage capacity
there's the 512 and that's starting at
11.99
[Music]
it is really great using this macbook
air because it's so small i'm so used to
traveling with now the 16-inch macbook
pro which considering it's quite large
so having this on a flight or going to
classes it's so light it's so small it's
so compact but i think what's really
important is the fact that they're able
to hit a 9.99 price point plus be able
to get all these upgrades so the three
main upgrades you've got the new
keyboard you also have a starting
configuration of 256 gigs of storage and
it has a faster cpu a faster gpu and
it'll be able to handle most daily tasks
and you probably shouldn't flip your
computer around like that especially me
i do want to do a size comparison though
of this and the 16 inch macbook pro
oh look what i have here i do have a d
brand skin on this and it is pink so my
computer
is not actually pink so you can
definitely see a size difference i mean
this would probably fit in one of my
small purses this obviously is much
bigger it is way more powerful you
really do need to take into
consideration like what are you using
this computer for you can definitely get
away with editing video on this no doubt
about it i will actually do a video test
so i will prove it to you that yes you
can edit video on here if you want
something that's a small form factor you
want an inexpensive mac this is it here
you go so these speakers now have two
times more bass 25 more volume it also
has the three microphone array that is
in the
new 16-inch macbook pro they're making a
really big deal about that because they
were saying that there's a
professional-grade microphone built in
to your macbook already and i will say
that i've recorded a lot of vo projects
a bunch of things that people probably
would have thought that i had a
professional crazy microphone set up but
i really just use my microphone on my
macbook inside of a closet and you would
never even know
let's go test out the speakers and the
microphone so i'm gonna go in this
closet over here it's
i don't even know
i'm not sure if i'm gonna fit
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm gonna get a copyright strike and you
know what if bon jovi were to give me a
copyright strike i would accept it
because it's bon jovi i've been
listening to bon jovi non-stop i've been
in the house for a while did i make that
with your crayolas i did i got some
sharpies i was like i'm going to make
you this really nice welcome to the
staple center how long have you been on
tour february march and this is it was
the third
[Applause]
i'm so glad you guys could all be here
today
there's nobody here yet but soon this
entire place will be filled with bon
jovi fans me included these speakers are
incredible like it's actually really
really loud
john is here himself so now it's time to
record some vo normally i don't actually
use this closet i use a closet that has
a lot of clothes in it but this is my
office closet and
i just have a bunch of
gadgets in here so there's a little bit
of echo but i think it sounds pretty
good hey guys it's justine i'm here in
the closet recording some vo this is a
nice day there's my dog you can hear him
in the background that's really all i
have to say i hope you enjoy it have a
nice day so if i sent that to a vo
casting agent do you think i'd get the
job that's really all i have to say i
hope you enjoy it have a nice day
i mean it sounds great i i mean i don't
have to say that it sounds good because
i've used this in many projects and no
one would ever even know that i was
recording directly off of my macbook can
i come out now
oh yeah sure okay
[Music]
so i'm going to do a really quick edit
just to see how this handles video
editing i'm going to be editing a video
about the gnarbox you guys may have seen
this before this is basically like a
hard drive but you can put sd cards into
it and you can connect this directly to
your ipad this can act as an external
drive this is so incredible when you're
out on the go you can just pop your sd
cards in you can do automatic backups of
cards i'll definitely be making another
video about this but if you're wondering
what i'm editing this is what i'm
working on so i'm gonna make a little
multi-cam clip here i'm also gonna be
screen capturing this at the same time
so that's gonna be putting some added
pressure on the system
[Music]
it's running really well yeah yeah
i've been a huge fan of gnarbox for a
while like not only am i editing a
multi-cam i'm also screen capturing like
it's running great are you using proxies
or no what's the is it set to better
performance i did put better performance
yeah i'm pretty impressed so really
check this out and test it can i just
see yeah come here i'll show you with my
sony
that's impressive i know it's definitely
not shooting
it hasn't even rendered in the timeline
like nothing like it hasn't transcoded
i'm editing this basically just raw and
i'm editing off of the solid state drive
that is not a fast one because i forgot
about that too well i'm going to keep
editing this so if you guys want to hear
a follow up on how the editing is going
on the new macbook air follow me on
twitter or instagram and check out my
instagram stories and i will give you
guys a follow-up there but so far i'm
really excited about this and i'm really
glad that they were able to make a
really great price point but also
increase the specs i think that's really
important so i'm gonna go i'm gonna keep
editing and let me know if there's
anything else you guys would like to
know about this or really anything i'll
see you guys in the comments
bye
looks so good
i think right now more than ever people
are questioning what is the perfect
computer or what is the perfect device
for me i think you really do need to
think about like what are you going to
be doing if you're doing a lot of high
intensive editing editing 4k 8k this
might not be the computer that you do
want to choose you might want to look
into getting more of the upgrade with a
macbook pro this is the machine that's
perfect for doing word processing for
writing to do photo editing but if you
are looking to do more high production
then i definitely think that a macbook
pro might be right up your alley but for
everything else like this is an
incredible computer let's also go
through and see if we can spec out what
the high end specs of this thing can be
we're gonna add a 1.2 gigahertz quad
core 10th gen i7 16 gigs of ram 2
terabytes of storage and that will bring
us up to
so that's kind of a first look at the
new macbook air i'm definitely really
excited about this this is something
that i do love taking with me when i'm
traveling or if i'm out on shoots i
don't want to bring a big computer so
depending upon your computing needs i
think there's so many different options
that apple has but if you are a beginner
if you're going to school definitely
take advantage of those educational
discounts because that's huge thank you
guys so much for watching i hope you
guys enjoyed this video i would love to
hear from you guys what is the one thing
that you most are looking for in a
laptop is it ram is it storage is it
processor speeds i'd love to know don't
forget to subscribe like this video hit
the bell and that's i think i think
that's all the things that i'm supposed
to tell you that you have to do
okay bye
[Applause]
and one second i gotta go get it that's
how this works
oh look what i have here